اتصل بنقيب المحامين وابلغني ان هناك لقاء
وتم يعني
التواصل مباشر بيني وبين الجانب الامريكي
اتصل
بممثل عن الجانب الامريكي
وطلب مني الحضور يوم 16/12 الساعه ثمانيه
تحت نصب عباس بن فرناس
رحت يعني
[موسيقى]
ودعت اسرتي
وفجرا
لانه الجانب الامريكي يتقيد بالمواعيد
فوصلت بغداد على الموعد
وترجلت من السياره التي تقلني
وافراد الحمايه اللي هم من اقاربي ومن
ابناء المنطقه
وبعضهم من فصائل المقاومه ترجلت وانسحبوا
بعيدا وجاءني الضابط الامريكي
وادخلني الى داخل
يعني
حدود المنطقه العفو
يسمونها النقطه صفر
اعتذر مني لاني يعني
اصعد معهم في العربه
الامريكيه المدرعه
على اعتبار ان مدني ولا يعني يجوز ان نصعد
بعربه امريكيه واكد لي ان الضروره الامنيه
تستوجب يعني اكون معهم في هذه العربه
صعدت معهم وكنت لا ارى يعني اي شيء
بالضبط كي لا اعرف اين الرئيس وايضا
المنطقه هي عسكريه
فبعد 45 دقيقه وصلنا الى المكان المطلوب
وفتح عدد لانه
المدرعه هي مدرعه ضد الرصاص
ففتح اربعه من
العسكريين المارينز بعضهم ضباط الباب
وترجلت منها
ودخلت الى طبعا التفتت اني الى الوراء كي
اعرف بالضبط المكان اللي انا فيه
يعني جلب انتباههم هذا
التفاته مني جلبت انتباههم
ودخلت الى الكلودور وحديث يعني طويل كان
بيني وبينهم